i love lucy
all these lights hold up yes dear are
you using your powers to turn on the
light
yes dude yes
what do you see only your lovely rose
bushes
that's all are you using your night
vision vision
you have absolutely no reason why is
like that now you know there are a lot
of theories uh floating around online as
to what the show is
and i want to run a couple of by you i
know you can't confirm
or deny but i thought maybe we could get
a read from you
here's one vision's tie is a clue now
let's zoom in on vision's tie
there are two dots inside the rectangle
you need two dots on the outside and i
guess the idea is that your characters
are trapped inside uh something and
also on the outside where you either
can't get in
or can't get out any of that ring a bell
the thing is is all of all of these
easter eggs
even if they were real they would go way
above
my head oh sure welcome back to new rock
stars
one division is one week away from
launching the multiverse saga
of the marvel cinematic universe and we
have some
questions we'll call them some big old
wtfs well not standing for anything
profane but rather
wanda the this is
inside marvel new rock stars one
division after show
i'm eric voss here with one of the
truly smartest marvel comics nerds that
i know a rogue theory finalist from the
past year comedian from collegehumor
and from our defunct sketch team slash
theater company we did a play
we didn't play jessica clemons um
we did do a play we did do a play um
and everyone that's watching that didn't
come see our play i'm very disappointed
in you but thank you
for having me on this i'm so excited to
talk
wanda maximoff and honestly any kind of
sorcery and also
any type of hell yeah any type of hell a
hell we may be trapped in at the moment
um
but hey you know let's escape into some
fictional hells
for once please uh i would really love
this
jessica i'm so glad that we could have
you join us each week to do this because
uh you know we i grew up reading certain
comics i didn't necessarily grow up
reading all the marvel comics i've since
read house of m
and uh the west coast avengers and uh
the tom king vision
uh but it's there's a lot of gaps in my
knowledge but i feel like talking with
you
you have read so many of the other like
uh secret invasion
secret wars stuff that's come out
recently uh and you actually grew up
reading that stuff
and weren't like a later convert like i
was so i
i we have um some similar but
complimentary expertise that's going to
make
watching this series with us really
great for anyone watching right now
absolutely more or less like i
definitely did get into a lot of
major major ones when i got older i
definitely stuck with like the
everything that everyone knew like i
knew batman and i was obsessed with
harley quinn i was obsessed with
um just like any dc really when i was
younger and
a little bit of marvel it wasn't until i
was older when i was like i have the
mental capacity now to add one and one
together and know that x-men
relate to this that relate to that yeah
so it like
i definitely think we will definitely
fill in each other's gaps especially
when it comes to wanda vision and the
television kind of person like where
we're gonna go into
yeah i and that is like i love wanda
maximoff i
think she's my favorite marvel's uh
superhero
who knows um might be a villain
she's one of my favorite just because i
love sorcery i love her storyline
because it's so crazy
and then to put it into this series that
disney's now making where it's taking
from every type of like television show
that's
been iconic in years past is where like
we're in entertainment
we watch these shows also just because
we're like this is what my family
watched
so it's it's hitting every nerve of my
body of like oh
i'm gonna get this tattooed on me soon
yeah oh for sure i mean
i you know i was definitely a child at
tv land growing up watching
freaking you know happy days and i love
lucy and bewitched and being like
people like this stuff and now i get the
charm of it i mean i definitely grew up
in the
you know late 80s early 90s watching the
abc
full house step-by-step family matters
you know i was a
an urkel stan of course you were
of course you were you are urkel go home
go home
but yeah now uh tgif is gonna be right
here on new rockstars because every
friday jessica and i are going to be
answering the biggest wtfs you had
coming out of each episode of
wandavision
uh and then the following day as always
i will do
my custom shot by shot easter egg
analysis of the subtler details you
missed those aren't going anywhere
so with both different formats we're
going to be fully covered throughout
these
nine episodes it turns out uh so
very very excited uh before we dive into
this preview for the season uh you all
remember how on our last after show for
the mandalorian we started these new
collectible traditions of uh to
celebrate whatever
our latest obsession is at any given
moment a way to wear our nerdum before
hot topic has even heard of mephisto
which
is weird because hot topic definitely
was founded in hell
well it is time to reveal our second
issue of the latest obsession line issue
number one was all about our crazy
indoctrination into the cult of
mandalore with our this is away shirt
and now that shirt is trapped back in
the blue dungeon it's sold out but it is
time for us to move on to something more
mind what the wanda e
because our latest obsession is the
biggest mind of all one division
and we made the shirt pretty dang extra
crazy so first up the grand reveal of
the new design
meet latest obsession number two an
unusual couple
as you can see the design is based on
the concept of vision's floating
consciousness or dare i say
robot soul being out there having some
sort of electric dreams
but how can we possibly know what he's
dreaming of well
to get in the mind of a robot you gotta
get advanced so ladies and gentlemen to
represent the complexity of the show
and the idea that the truth is somewhere
on the other side of the screen
this shirt comes to life through
augmented reality
when you order it you'll be given the
ability to access through an app the
secret world that vision soul is
externally experiencing
we've got a snippet of that experience
here
looks so cool but to see the whole thing
though you got to order the shirt
so go these things sell up pretty
quickly especially the sizes you want
so make sure not to wait too long oh and
as always we will be taking shout outs
with
shirt orders and addressing those on
this show each week hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com for all that we will
be here waiting
for you when you get back so with that
out of the way jessica
let's catch ourselves up on how wanna
envision got here
previously on one division of course
boss
so let's start let's start and let's
buckle up because this is gonna be a
wild ride for those that have not
watched any of the last six movies
uh wanda and vision have the weirdest
backstory of all the avengers they were
introduced into avengers age of ultron
wanda was one of the two maximoff twins
an enhanced individual
and hydra experimented on her using the
mind stone in sokovia activating sorcery
powers she's
telepathic capable of creating illusions
in people's minds she's telekinetic
allowing her to levitate objects and her
own body
but mostly her powers have been red hand
smoke yeah what is that
just whoa red hands i'm
don't even start with me don't even
start with me john can you do effects
um if not i look crazy right now
which is how elizabeth olsen feels doing
these hand dances
on sets my favorite is oh my gosh
when doctor strange does them anytime
i'm always like what does this look like
before
[Laughter]
and i'm just like oh my god he is
aggressive either way i'm obsessed with
her red hand smoke do not make fun of it
uh in the comic scarlet witch wanda
maximoff is a mutant the daughter of
magneto from a young age she was cursed
by the demon cathon
with chaos magic allowing her to warp
the fabric of reality
making her the coolest superhero i'm
sorry i will say it again
she is bad ass vision was also
introduced in age of ultron
he was an android made of vibranium
enriched synthetic flesh with the mine
stone plugged into his head
intended to be the final form body for
ultron but tony stark and bruce banner
uploaded him with the os of jarvis
and then thor woke him up gently with
lightning um
if you remember that scene it was just a
pleasant it was so
sweet and dainty of thor to wake him up
with like what an insane uh origin story
like i have to read it from a list of
everything that went into making vision
i like i mean it speaks more to like
joss whedon's writing and age of ultron
where it just seems like he's just
throwing everything against the wall
and hopes someone comes out of it i
rewatched age of ultron over the winter
break and i
first off a if you haven't watched age
of ultron since it's come out
please do um it is so fun to re-watch
because thor is so small it's so
small and his character just is
so different than what he is now he
completely is different
but for visions like origin and coming
up into story it was like
i don't know i don't know if we're gonna
get too into ultron i
i liked it though ultron was very
dependent on humanity
which like he shouldn't be but
that's that's a fight for me and joss
whedon well that's what i hope
one division can kind of revisit some of
that stuff and clear it up like uh
age of ultron is is i think underrated
it did a lot to
build up the groundwork for what was so
great about infinity war and end game
but like as a movie there's still a lot
of huss but i think those
goods could be ohs after we watch one
division
they try going back to it like slightly
every they're always like oh you
remember this
place this planet that like or another
planet this country that is like fell on
the ground and exploded and i'm like
yeah we remember it but can you talk
about it more
because they only like to bring back
that clip of it floating in the air
yeah but either way i digress that's
where vision brought was brought into
the framework that's when we all saw him
for the first time was like oh he's
sexy um vision vision is also insanely
powerful he can fly
move at super speeds phase shift through
surfaces and fire energy beams from the
infinity stone in his head he
died in front of the war when thanos
ripped the stone out of his head
and he was one of the few avengers not
to return an end game his death was
before the snap
and permanent end games ends with wanda
still grieving over his death
this was a part that i could not wrap my
head around when i first saw
the movie for some reason i was like no
he would come back
oh he would come back and i it took me
like a very long time to recognize
no this was way before he did the snap
right right uh and like
spider-man far from home made that
official with their you know
their tribute video at the beginning of
the movie vision was there uh it was
shutter stock imagery
so uh yeah vision's gonzo
but now it's pretty gonzo how the hell
he's back um
uh and it seems like you know wanda
seems like
still pretty bitter over that as she
should be she's also bitter over the
fact that she lost her brother she's
lost so much
she's lost a ton yeah and i think that's
reasonably
so she's allowed to be this crazy like
this mad she's allowed to be
all of this i'm right here goes with
reason yeah absolutely and i think that
is why kevin feige has kind of said
she's now gonna be the strongest avenger
she has the most to avenge
uh she has that anger in her heart and
uh when thanos was like i don't even
know who you are she's like you will
uh i think that was to all of us you
know a promise that like
you're gonna find out how freaking crazy
badass i can be and this show seems to
be
showing us that um have we found out
whether because they did bring up
momentarily that she might be a villain
for the next yeah i would love
i love a villain i love a villain i'm
though always that person
that's rooting for the villains in
movies i'm always like because we need
them in order to make the movie
do you think we might get that instead
do you think they might switch it up
uh in this show it might be showing the
origin story of a villain oh we'll talk
about that a little bit later with yeah
saga but like yeah she's going back and
doctor strange multiverse of madness i
think it's going to be as that movies
villain
yes yes yes yes yes yes um so what's our
our first big
wtf wanda the heading
into this monovision series uh do you
want me to say wanda though
every time i say whatever it evolves
into that's what it should be
wanda the is going on in wanda
sitcom reality what is this show boss
yeah okay so yeah let's start there
here's what we know
so in one division vision's back uh or
some form of him is
as uh part of this pocket reality is
what we're calling it right now it's a
bubble
that wanda envisioned all these other
people are contained within
uh and this bubble encases the town of
westview
uh and that's where wanda and vision are
living in a series of
sitcoms home lives so the reality
toggles among a series of these sitcom
tropes
uh apparently based on classic sitcoms
like i love lucy
bewitched and the dick van dyke show in
the clip we just watched the beginning
episode um elizabeth
since said that they were borrowing from
bewich and the dick van dyke show dick
van dyke himself
consulted on this show uh obviously
there's some references to the brady
bunch
family ties maybe full house which
starred elizabeth olsen's sisters the
olsen twins
uh roseanne and a modern family the
latest
big abc sitcom where they she appears to
be doing some talking head stuff and in
some of these trailers
um i think with with that being said
when they were talking about that in the
trade
or when they were talking about that in
the video and they said that um
dick van dyke was like a consultant
basically do you think that means that
like they're gonna stay on the dick van
dyke show for a very long episode
because i thought they were going to
like kind of go through them very
quickly
but then i was like i doubt they talked
to roseanne's consultants for that no
no i was like yeah i had a theory at one
point that they were gonna
only touch him with abc shows because
it's owned by disney and they have
licensing rights to uh all of roseanne
modern family
uh a lot of these shows all the tgif
shows were abc not all the ones they
referenced some of these were on like
cbs i think it's just gonna be
references
uh and i think with dick van dyke the
reason they consulted with him is he
back in the day was like he understood
the formula of like
how this stuff works how to get your
performers to do like
live-action multi-cam type acting how to
play for laughs
but not in a way that feels too like
cringy or annoying
um and one thing we learned from that
entertainment weekly article they shot
this
on a multi-cam set all those scenes were
shot in front of live studio audiences
and that's why they feature a lot of
these special effects and editing styles
like you can see elizabeth and paul
bettany are playing to a crowd which is
new
for all these marvel actors to try to do
i would literally
uh sell my left leg to have been in that
audience
that would make a great idea just to
just to see it just to see
i would have given them my entire life
savings
to be in that room also because i would
have been like paying attention i've
been like okay where's all these eggs at
i know they're real what's that wine
bottle
be like yeah where's that house of them
i see it i would absolutely would be i
would go crazy on it yeah
but also yeah i'm very that's why i'm so
into this freaking show they did all
that they didn't have to do all that but
they did
they committed so hard uh and but
underneath all of this
wanda is not apparently in full control
of this pocket reality sometimes wanda
and vision are
in character participants of the sitcom
reality other times you can see kind of
in their eyes the walls are crumbling
literally the walls are crumbling as
they're realizing oh this is like an
eternal sunshine reality
uh this is inception this is not real um
she envisioned or asked like how they
got there they have no idea
and then at one point there's a voice
from the outside that sounds like jimmy
wu saying wanda who is doing this to you
which makes it sound like even outside
observers know that wanda herself
isn't totally running the show uh there
was also the previous scene we watched
to begin this episode where
there's you know they kind of laugh it
off but there is this creepy
violent bump in the night that is waking
them up what is that
uh wanda and vision don't know so
clearly there's some stuff going on
outside their control
i'm gonna say right now i'm gonna drop
the idea and if this is right i want
everyone watching to give me ten
twenty dollars i think it's gonna be
someone that
appeared in that universe that's not
supposed to be in there just like monica
and they're just walking
into the wall of their home like kind of
like
the simulated rick and morty reality of
just the mailman like my name oh yeah
it's the truth 110
it's the man it's a it's a glitch
in this matrix it's just a black cat
running into a mailbox over and over
again
someone that is just like i'm trying to
get out but i can't
and they're just like running into their
front door a bunch of times oh
i would love that i would love that well
all of this
all of west view is being externally
monitored by sword and this is where we
start to connect to the mcu so sword is
an
offshoot of shield in the marvel comics
it stands for sentient world observation
and response department
normally they're like headquartered in
earth's orbit and they're focused on
extraterrestrial threats but in this
case it looks like sword
is observing and responding to the
sentient world of this
wanda pocket reality so jimmy wu from
ant-man the wasp
uh darcy lewis from the thor movies and
monica rambo a grown-up from
captain marvel uh they're all part of
this version of sword
and we are starting to see a bunch of
sword easter eggs in
a trailer footage so uh there's that
logo where it's a circle and the sword
jutted up from it
it looks like some of swords forces are
getting warped into and assimilated into
this pocket reality when they get too
close to it
so monica rambo she warps into a sitcom
background character
in a recent video i talked about she has
this necklace that you know
at first glance it kind of looked like
an upside down cross which i was like
moving around mephisto but
a lot of you uh corrected me yeah that
is the sword logo
uh which i'm bummed i missed it because
that sword logo shows up on this toy
helicopter
that one defines that i think might be
the outside life-size helicopter that
just gets turned into a harmless toy
um and then uh the sword logo shows up
on the back of that beekeeper
who climbs out of the sewer so i think
that could be another sword agent who is
infiltrating and then it just he turns
into a beekeeper when he comes into this
reality
that same logo that's on the back of the
beekeeper is the wallpaper for all the
i think it was the movie theater that
when they were riding their bike through
i saw there was little
and i was like i didn't look it up i
should have looked it up i was like
this is a symbol from infesto i i'm so
deep in bethesda that i refuse to
acknowledge anything else that i was
like
what a good find jessica uh good spot
there yeah and um and
a lot of marvel insiders know that on
the back of that uh
pager that nick fury was paging captain
marvel with at the post-credits scene of
infinity war
uh the prop team released that on the
back of it is the sword logo
uh so all of this is connecting uh in
fact that might be where nick fury was
in the post-credits scene apart from
home he might have been on the peak
that's the sword space station
so a lot of people were asking about
catherine han's character she is playing
agnes uh who looks to be some kind of
neighbor or friend of wanda who also
seems to be uh trapped in the bubble
she's warping up through the decades
uh playing like a kimmy gibler type
character in the 80s one
though a lot of thinking is that agnes
is a version of the character
agatha harkness so they take the ag and
the nests and they got
agnes uh agatha harkness in the comics
is a witch who poses as a friend to
wanda but is actually a servant of
mephisto which for me is where all this
mephisto theorizing starts
mafisto you only asked me to be on this
show because you know i'm deep in
mephisto too
you're on team of business only mephisto
stands right now
i cannot wait to just be proven wrong
it's gonna be a nightmare and i'm gonna
be so upset
i keep thinking about this i keep
thinking about this i'm gonna be so
mad we'll get into it a little bit later
why i will be pissed if it's nightmare
but like
oh my god if it is i put my money on me
so we're gonna talk a lot about mephisto
why i'm so obsessed with him and
how we hope he's the true antagonist of
the series but first we want to thank
some friends who helped us make this
episode
our friends at audible thank you to
audible for sponsoring this episode
audible is of course the leading
provider of
spoken word entertainment and audiobooks
bestsellers and new releases sci-fi
comedy true crime they got it all
with audible membership you can download
titles and listen
offline anytime anywhere the audible app
is free and can be installed on all
smartphones and tablets you can listen
across
devices without losing your spot that's
awesome
and now audible is giving members even
more with the all-new
plus catalog all members have access to
the growing plus catalog
with thousands of audio books and
podcasts audible originals
guided fitness and meditation programs
sleep tracks for better rest
and more all included with membership
audible has a big collection of marvel
content that our fans would absolutely
love
including audible novelizations of all
the mcu films
and a bunch of great comics story lines
like planet hulk and secret wars
they also have the great content you'd
expect from authors like stephen king
margaret atwood
and tom clancy they've got great fitness
and wellness content for folks looking
to support those new year's resolutions
squeezing a workout or guided meditation
without having to go to the gym or a
class
start exploring audible with a free
30-day trial right now
visit audible.com wandavision or text
one division to 500 500 to start your
free 30-day trial that's audible.com
one division or text one division to 500
to start your free 30-day trial all
right jessica
back to our next wanda the
i wanda the i'm here for it um
disney can never sponsor you're like
who's doing this awanda and why
this is my 80s convoy so i'm trying
really hard
whoa uh so just
as you know our theory has been mephisto
uh that is a name i brought up way too
much during my investigations it's going
to make me sound a bit like a
laughingstock mephisto
is of course the devil figure from
marvel comics he
is at thanos society during the infinity
gauntlet event in the comics
uh we bring up mephisto for this reason
he connects to wanda in a very important
way
in the west coast adventures comics in
the 80s wanda and vision go through an
event that is almost
exactly similar to what is happening in
one division now
wanda has two babies who are looked
after
by agatha the witch but we find out that
those babies
are puppet illusions they're part of a
pretty complicated plot but at the end
of the day we find out that those babies
are kind of parts of methisto's soul and
mephisto's plan is to try to steal
wanda's chaos magic but in the end the
babies are basically reabsorbed
into mephisto wand is heartbroken and
then years and years later wanda tries
to manifest them back to life
in house of m and later we find out that
those children are the reborn mutants
wiccan
in speed so the theory is that this show
one division will kind of adapt all this
that uh they'll make mephisto the evil
spirit that is haunting wanda
right now using her powers to warp this
reality in order to give her a happy
home life with vision
all designed to distract her as he
drains her of her magic
and that this will lead to a kind of
multiverse crisis with mutants existing
in the mcu
via magic we'll talk about that but we
should acknowledge that there are other
possibilities
mephisto isn't the only demonic presence
who could be doing this to wanda
like there's nightmare from the dream
dimension the rumored villain of doctor
strange to
others say this could all just be coming
from wanda herself like she has an inner
darkness and she just becomes the next
major villain
of the mcu and you don't need mephisto
tell that story this is
exactly what you summarize is why it has
to be mephisto
you're pulling so much from those series
that you can't just
change the main villain of it but
i i will say i do understand okay i
wanted to be memphis so
understand that full and full like
through and through i wanted to be
mephisto
but in a world that it is nightmare i
understand
how it could be nightmare because we're
trying to see him in the next uh
doctor strange movie and also nightmare
is pretty badass
it's uh freddy krueger uh so i
understand
well freddy krueger came after but you
know what i mean
i think it's really cool i think it's a
great idea and it also would bring this
idea that maybe
maybe i'm not going with the theory but
that wanda is just like asleep
and this is her uncle like this is her
like her dream state
is him controlling it and she's in like
some sort of coma which realistically
like as a she's not like a human she's a
mutant but like
but like what if she did what if we got
that in the marvel cinematic universe
that like she instead of having this
abrupt
house of m situation of her bringing
everything like to her own being
what if she was asleep what if she was
asleep and this is
like just a madness house i know that'd
be cheap
not cheap it would be upsetting as a
viewer to be like this was all a dream
but then that's all the reason why we'd
have nightmare yeah it was all a dream
yeah um it would give reason to why we
have nightmare and he is cool and also
we'd get club fear which is
honestly a sick title for our club and
we'd get to see it
now a lot of people are shooting down
the mephisto theory because of china
so just to give you a bit of an
explanation there uh
the chinese film board is pretty
hands-on with
censoring any content that is broadcast
in china and a lot of movies uh
big hollywood movies have to be careful
what kind of content they put in there
if there's any kind of like ghosts or
demons if there's anything that's
critical of the chinese government or
mentions tibet
the chinese government be like we're not
gonna broadcast this movie in our very
lucrative
billion person strong movie watching
market
the thing with uh and there was some
talk that maybe that's what happened
with doctor strange's multiverse madness
why scott derrickson as director had to
step down because he really wanted
that guy's a horror director he loves
like demonic stuff
but one division is only on disney plus
disney plus is not
in china so that kind of frees up the
creators of one division to tell
whatever kind of story they want
and you know a couple years from now
when disney plus does
open in the chinese market they just
don't have to show wandavision or they
can remove certain episodes and
we're all going to be moved on to uh
ant-man kwanda mania at that point
that's true oh okay i never knew that
but that makes complete sense
it's the door is still open for this
devil if they want to bring him in now
that's
okay so that's a fight that's a good
argument not good enough for me not to
have mafesto
in it i'm like please put him in i get
that that's a great argument
yeah if they do i want the and i also
just want the bethesda one because i
would love to see
wanda as the villain that is how are you
gonna top thanos like how are you gonna
do it that's how i think that's like
what we all kept asking about that's
what i kept asking myself
and to have a superhero that was
fighting that was inside on the marvel
team become the villain
that's a real thing that's like could
you kill your own did you have your own
hell yeah so i'm for it i'm gonna say
it's mafesto i'll put
i keep betting in this i don't know why
but i'll put my mom on it
if i lose you guys can have my mother me
vista will take her soul
if you're wrong oh no wait not the soul
whatever
oh my god i didn't think this dude is
the monkey's paw all over again
yeah i fall for this every time all
right what's our next big question
coming into this okay okay um
how is vision back and will he survive
after the series
will he survive after this series are we
gonna cry at the end of the series
i think there will be some tears i'm
gonna cry i cry easily though i cry
commercials i'm that person
i'm going to cry at the end of this
movie this series i know i am
oh god an explanation i really like is
that vision
could be part of the same logic that
anything that gets too close to this
pocket reality gets assimilated into it
and reframed into something wanda wants
so like a helicopter gets turned into a
toy a harmless toy
vision's corpse could have been brought
into or near this pocket reality they
throw
corpse her magic warps him back to life
in her
eyes they throw his car they kind of
drag it in there
or or or maybe uh like agnes
procured the corpse for her agnes dug up
this corpse and then she's like
let's do a weird seance thing and then
it works and she gets trapped in there
too
right okay uh this is the stuff i feed
off of i love this or like
agnes brings in wanda into wherever
visions corpse
kept in some like weird you know shield
lab or something like that
and she's like i have this dark hole i
have a spell that can bring him back
and she's like all right let's try it
let's try it let's try it and then
like a whole west view town grows out
from there
i love those this it's funny because i
and i i recognize now being on the show
i'm like
jessica you stick so hard to your theory
it gets warped and you believe that it's
how the show's gonna go and so i'm like
you're wrong i'm right
um and we might talk about this later so
feel free to i guess
edit this out john if i do if we are
talking about this later so how i
potentially thought
vision was coming back for a slight
second what i was noticing
was with all the jewelry everyone's
jewelry pieces right so if
mephisto is oh wait is my internet are
you saying they're good oh
you were so still you were dead still i
thought i'd cut out
yeah i'm gonna throw your body into your
body
so the jewelry if mafesto is living in
it i did notice with
monica's it was white silver when she
was like what's up what's going on and
then when she came to and was like i
don't know it was turning blue and then
when she got shot through the space we
didn't see it at all um and so i was
like
okay let's hold on to this jewelry bit
and then when agatha was had her jewelry
on
that little symbol i don't know if it
was in her dress or
you just couldn't see it but i couldn't
see it when she was dressed up as a
witch
so when she was like she did that line
of are you am i dead no why would you
say that because you are
it could be coming from the actual
actual agatha because
she didn't have that pendant on yet so i
was like i think mephisto can
only control people when they have that
pendant on and then i was like
what if she's making up vision what if
she's making a vision her entire self
that's why he can't leave the orb
but then also on top of that he's just
as confused at the exact same pieces
that wanda is like the exact same stuff
it's not like stuff that's just like
yeah why would he know that it's the
exact every time she has an answer he
has an answer
every time she's confused on a specific
fact he's also confused on that specific
fact
so i'm like what if this is just made by
her vision is just her
and that's why he knows just as much as
wanda knows and when wanda's like
this is our home we have to protect it
he's like yes we have to protect it he's
always like yes and yes and i'm like
this is because she created him yeah
he's
kind of her imaginary friend right yeah
it's her imaginary friend and that's why
i think i'm gonna cry at the end because
she can't take him out of that world and
she's gonna recognize that
and that's when i'm gonna be like
this is how i cry
i cry like arnold schwarzenegger and so
yeah i like that take right like she's
in a dollhouse of her own making and in
order to come back to reality she has to
leave all of her little dollies behind
but that's when we might get into her
being a villain because she's like i'm
gonna go man i don't have my dollies
anymore
yeah this is mine that's why i think
vision's not gonna i don't think vision
can survive this series this is part of
her
learning to kind of let go of vision but
on the other side of it
rather than peace and stability she's
rage filled
either way it's gonna be messy i don't
think vision's gonna be in another thing
he's not gonna survive
to play devil's advocate also paul benny
has brought up tons of times how he
he was like i was happy when i was just
a voice now i have to come on the set
and dress up completely in this
outfit at least sometimes he gets to
just uh wear his normal face and they do
his hair
differently he's like okay i'll do it at
half the time i don't have to wear the
red makeup yeah if i don't have to be in
costume for eight hours
he definitely i was like be happy you
got away with it in one division you are
rarely in your out like envision outfit
yeah all right what's the next uh
question
wonder will one division return to
wanda's origin
and feature quicksilver that's a good
question that's a good question
it's a good one and uh we theorized this
before some of the recent trailers but
yeah now trailer footage is straight up
showing wanda in her inmate guard when
she was a test patient at that hydra
facility in sokovia an age of ultron
and we see her gazing at the mind stone
we know it's a mind stone because it's
yellow but it also had that weird blue
casing
from when it was in the scepter before
marvel decided to just make it the
yellow mine stone
but the uh there's another shot that
shows the whole external facade of that
base on her dining room wall as the
house is warping around her
uh and so from all this we know that
there's gonna be some kind of flashback
uh some memory of wanda's origin and
hopefully that will better explain how
the mind stone activated her powers
and whether she was already born with
certain genetic predispositions
uh a mutant x gene now that disney's
allowed to say the word mutant
legally legally explain why she and
pietro were successful test subjects
uh which brings us to quick silver yeah
pietro
was there at the time but there's been
no uh rumors of aaron taylor johnston
appearing on the show though we have
heard that evan peters which is
interesting casting because he played
quicksilver in the fox x-men movies
is gonna play some mystery role could be
quicksilver
could be mephisto i pitched in my rogue
theory that i think mephisto will be the
face of quick
or will be the face of quicksilver which
will be evan peters
and i was like i think evan peters will
be a mafesto but in that like
psychological world of like he's trying
to mess with her more
right here's your brother um but then
they do do that flashback i saw in the
trailer and i was like okay so are we
getting that quicksilver
right aaron taylor johnson it'd be a
huge reveal
uh because he's a pretty big name and a
lot of these scoopers are pretty on
these casting reports on the travel
schedules on the social media so
it would have been a pretty well kept
secret if he does show up on this show
uh or maybe it's just like archive
footage from when they shot those scenes
in age of ultron and post-credits
i think it is just to be like remember
this yeah
uh but where she started if you could
get anyone to play mephisto
why do you choose the guy who played
quicksilver in another movie universe it
seems deliberate doesn't it well yeah
exactly it's too deliberate
it's too deliberate they that is to the
every single person in that room even me
that'd be serving waters would be like
that's not a good idea
unless you're trying to make something
of this idea like and so i'm sure
that has to that's why i thought my
theory i was like it has to be something
like that
like why would you bring him in that
world evan peters
yeah so uh our next question our next
next
uh what is house of m and how could one
division establish the x-men in the mcu
uh jessica and i both are familiar with
house of m but for anyone who's not
familiar with it
why is he coming up house of m is
basically the best and most famous
scarlet witch story line in marvel
comics if you're gonna do
a wanda story on uh film or tv
you do house of them uh it's so cool
house of m begins with
wanda kind of chaotically resetting
reality to try to invoke
uh a life with her children that she
that were taken from her
uh but it just gets too out of control
too chaotic so the avengers and the
x-men have a very
very serious meeting where they're like
so we're going to kill her
we're going to end her life that's what
we're going to get in the next
the next movie so we're going to kill
wanda we're her friend but like also
she's kind of going
she's doing something she's going nuts
uh but so pietro
uh quicksilver is like uh hell no and he
intervenes he goes to magneto and then
suddenly
everything flashes white and then
reality is reset
so that mutants not no longer
second-class citizens they are now
running society the house of m uh
standing for house of magus
it's magneto's name he is now kind of
like the ruler of this reality
wolverine that uh always really
healing uh cool dude is the only one who
remembers how things used to be
so he is now on this mission try to
awaken each superhero and whatever new
life they're in to be like hey this is
wrong right
and they're like oh yeah yeah yeah so it
ends up in a big fight and then wanda
basically in the middle of this fight
whispers
the famous words no more mutants and
then
uh reality is restored back to normal
except
the vast majority of mutants have been
erased from existence
one of the craziest things to happen in
all of marvel comics
uh so we're thinking we might see a uh
version
of that now in the mcu but like a
reversal so that wanda might just say no
more mutants you know no comma more
mutants like the lionel
more mutants that would be cool what if
okay as you read that out loud i was
just like what if
which i would be insane i guess
everything's insane about this series
if we are doing the timeline where
she opens the multiverse basically
everyone and then we get all our movies
and entering the multiverse but at the
end of the multiverse
or not the end of the multiplayer the
end of the one division series that's
when she does the
no more mutants like that kind of thing
if it builds
yeah yeah and now you have to be like
now i gotta go watch dr strange i have
to watch the new spiderman i have to
watch the new all
just because at the end of this series
she's gonna be like
no more mutants oh yeah see what i think
is and we'll get into this in in a
little bit um i don't know if
one division as a series will be the
story of house of them but i think
everything that comes after will be the
story of house of them that might be
what the multiverse saga
is it's basically house of m blowing
open the multiverse to lots of different
realities parallel timelines
we know house of m is important to
marvel studios the infinity war and
endgame screenwriters said that they
actually wanted to try to work in house
of m
to one of those movies that but those
were obviously way too big of movies
they didn't have
room to fit it in but marvel studios
it's on their
wish list of things to adapt so it's
going to show up somewhere in this
multiverse saga
uh and also there's the wine bottle we
were talking about the uh
it has the label saying that meson du
mexi which uh
uh it has an m as a logo a monthly
uh it translates to like house of misery
really it's house of contempt
but that m a lot of people see this as
like a house of m easter i love house of
m h
if you are watching this and you haven't
read house of m try to find it it's
probably hard to find now
that one division's coming out and it's
kind of pricey but it's worth the read
it's hard because the marvel universe
has already taken
pietro out and so it's like
okay so we can't do like too much house
of m
but we can give a little bit and i want
so badly for all of it i would love
because we'd get like all these
different universes
all these different madnesses when she
kills all the mutants she has like she
starts jumping from planet to planet
making her own life
so it's like which is kind of one
division the series that's what they're
essentially doing it's like different
episodes different
realities but she was going like planet
to planet
so like if we could get that that would
be pretty cool that's why i think uh
because house of m is so bonkers and the
way they're doing one division seems to
be pretty grounded in sitcom tropes i
think it's just going to be like the
overture the precursor to the house of
him
and then the crazy crazy stuff will be
in these titles that come out in phase
four afterwards
and which brings us to our our last uh
one of the
this whole idea of the multiverse saga
uh why are they calling one division to
start the multiverse saga
what does that mean so this is kind of
our big question going forward
i think it's pretty clear that wanda
vision is linked to these other mcu
phase four titles
kind of a three four or five part event
that is going to feature the multiverse
as a backdrop uh we know wanda returns
and doctor strange multiverse madness
we know that movies can be preceded as
by spider-man 3 where doctor strange is
going to be in it
and some kind of spider-verse plot that
sam raimi director of doctor strange 2
is clearly consulting on
also during this we know we're getting
loki which is going to deal with the tva
alternate timelines
uh we also know we're getting the
animated what if series with jeffrey
wright as watching the watcher our guide
through the multiverse
so in the way that like phases one
through three are now being redubbed by
marvel studios as the infinity saga
i think rather than stick to the word
you know phase four
they're gonna just start calling it the
multiverse saga that makes sense
yeah all these upcoming titles it's it's
going to either
acknowledge the existence of the
multiverse in some way either
they're going to be stories about how
these worlds connect with each other
or they're going to be stories about how
this is a side else world
story and that's how we're going to get
different genres that's how we're going
to get blade
that's how we're going to get the kung
fu movie of shang qi maybe that's how
we're going to get the eternals
uh these things that just feel like
they're in a different world than
something of like what iron man 2 was
set in you know or
that black widow was set in these could
all just be else worlds
uh but it also gives us the opportunity
to bring in miles morales
uh captain britain alternate sorcerers
supreme you know uh all this could start
next week with one division it's going
to be very fun i agree i truly
the multiverse saga just seems like it's
also it which i think you already
talked in or tapped into is the fact of
like yeah we have these phases and now
we have the multiverse saga that's like
here on their own and then once this is
done which is going to take 10 years
um we'll come back out with like then
we'll get back into the
like not phases but like a different
variety it's like the multiverse saga
is here for us to like get really into
because you can't get into marvel
without getting into it it's a huge
world
i just need to know when we're getting
into eternals
yeah i need to do this i need to look
into it more
i'm very behind on the eternals not in
general but just like when they're gonna
drop because
then they push it again maybe hopefully
i will get a trailer for that soon
because that's like oh i need it all
right we're gonna close out this episode
and hopefully every episode with a
segment that we are gonna call
what the devil uh so as i've stated
we've bet
pretty hard on this theory that mephisto
is gonna be the secret big bad of the
series
uh the devil pulling all the strings
actually to the point jessica
i don't know if you know this but people
are now making fun of me in the comments
of
every uh video in tweet that i post that
have nothing to do with wanda vision or
mephisto they're like oh here comes eric
talk about mephisto again
which is fine i get it you're gonna be
eating alive after this
drops
so what we're gonna do here and what the
devil we're gonna quickly just run down
some possible mephisto sightings or or
possible sightings to keep your eye on
to make some predictions of where he
could show up next so the devil is
everywhere he takes many forms
the devil is other people and so just to
remind you of
some things to keep your eye on some
trouble spots some red flags
first what the devil um wanda's
imaginary babies
just reminding you that in this west
coast avengers story
the fact that wanda has these babies
feels like it is part of that same
mevisto trick from those comics
so uh they come from somewhere vision
cannot procreate because he's an
android he does kind of have a purple
flesh stick that
betany has talked about but those babies
came from somewhere they seem to be
coming from some external place
and i think that could be this next uh
there's agnes and her pendant which we
talked about before
um if if agnes is agatha harkness
uh mephisto is what follows right
because accurate serves mephisto they're
kind of a package deal
agnes is dressed as a witch in the
halloween episode
seems to be going in that direction and
then she has this pendant that you
talked about then
yeah that pendant could be linked to
mephisto's control or presence
i concur then there's this mysterious
shadow figure
in the wall of west view uh in the
static
this looks kind of creepy okay i saw
that i
saw when you brought that up and i was
like okay this could be
anyone it could be anyone oh boy i'd
have a pistol jessica
why not i was like okay it could be
nightmare too and then i was also like
what if it's just uh darcy lewis and her
jacket going in the world
absolutely could be a milkman uh it
could just be a paper boy
evening tv it could just be a bike but
who knows maybe it's just me but we
should acknowledge our fourth
maybe devil sighting uh mephisto exists
elsewhere in the mcu right so uh there
was that um barely legible mentioned
mephisto on paperwork in the first
avengers movie so he's there
uh but also in the recent loki trailer
there was a stained glass depiction of a
red demonic figure that is probably
gonna be mephisto
so if these two series are linked uh
we're gonna look back on that and be
like oh
we we were given a clue i'm just saying
jessica i want all of us to be on the
lookout for anything satanic or demonic
in nature
if there are any creepy voices from the
beyond any kind of like
um uh what's it called the creepy
shadow king from legion you know any
kind of creepy demonic entity you're
like this is awfully good
i get the first two i'm
not that with you on the last two but i
get like hey
go on it's go on the shadow figure could
have been anybody
you're right we i have to mention it
just so that we can check in on this
next week i want to keep myself honest
as much as i can
if it turns out to be him then i'll be
like oh but if it's him
and someone else's body it doesn't count
i think
it counts no i could watch him like take
over monica and come through there and
you're like
okay well agree to disagree i don't
think if if the devil takes over your
soul it's still that damn oh
it's still what the devil that's what
she says that's what darcy lewis says as
soon as it comes out
that'd be wonderful well i think we've
exhausted all the big questions going
into this series
really all that's left now is to watch
the first episode coming out a week from
today i cannot wait
to dive into this with you jessica it's
gonna be real fun
you're gonna get so much of me i'm gonna
cry on the last episode and i will cry
on this podcast um
and that is it for this first preview
episode of the inside marvel uh we are
going to be back next
week to break down the biggest wtfs from
the series premiere and all possible
mephisto sightings thank you to jessica
joining me be sure to follow jessica uh
lulu clemens
on all social media uh and follow me at
ea boss follow new rock stars check out
our great merch options at new york
source merch.com jump on that latest
obsession one because it looks so cool
uh and we'll we'll include your shout
outs on on next week's episode
uh and we will see you next time uh
we're gonna close with our
favorite moment from uh from the
trailers
move from where married when damn it why
why
[Music]
you